and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Deadpool
oh my god this is a greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
boilers this is a prequel to Wolverine
Origins here's this guy named Jason Lee
if he worked out every day and he's an
assassin for teenage girls who have a
lot of money
a very broad market but he falls in love
with a prostitute while playing
skee-ball it is that Oakley she but she
suddenly finds out he has cancer I had
cancer once there was no way I can make
a joke that won't offend somebody so I
will just move on so he does what any
man in his position would do leaves his
girlfriend behind donates his body to
mad scientist's subjects himself to a
life of torture it's all in the name of
becoming a superhero it's like this guy
read my biography don't muscle-bound
Jason Lee is really upset
because it turns out a guy named Francis
lied to him they weren't making
superheroes they were making super
slaves with that's the last time I
agreed to go with a person who says he
can cure cancer and make me a superhero
you can't fool me eight times but
muscle-bound Jason Lee gets out of it by
burning himself alive often the answer I
usually choose and he's out to get
revenge as Deadpool the only problem is
he looks like Freddy Krueger made love
to an avocado oh wait there he made that
joke he says he doesn't want his mouth
sewn shut because it reminds him a
Wolverine origin 20 made that joke too
he wants to be sure not to be the next
pretty lancha well this is really hard
when you looking make so many
fourth-wall jokes what can I say about
it
oh I know when it's not making fourth
wall jokes the movie is actually kind of
boring let you know that Mark Wahlberg
and ice-t movie that you see advertised
like every other weekend the one where
they wear backwards hats and carry guns
the black to those movies is pretty much
the black - Deadpool he had a good life
until tragedy struck and he made the
wrong choices now one man is out for
revenge what they kidnapped his girl so
he's gonna have to break the rules yeah
you know the trailer to those movies you
never see that's it but when he does
make fourth wall joke it's really funny
it's like watching Bugs Bunny in
training day or something oh and one and
a half x-men are in it but seeing how
it's the only x-men character ever that
actually looks a hundred percent and
asks a hundred percent like an x-men
character that technically makes this
the best x-men movie ever if their names
are Colossus and some girl I've never
heard of before but she can blow up so I
think her name was Fantine ia's
combustion they worked on that away from
the theater that was a fun 20 miles
don't
Poulos ding with a blind lady who
everybody's gonna figure so her pet
isn't and he calls on the help of the
one and a half x-men to get us
girlfriend back and Deadpool is like
let's make literally one chimichanga
joking kick some ass and Colossus is
like oh come only you can make the
fourth wall jokes but we don't catch on
pool because I'm the only fictional
character who knows he's a fictional
character Oh nobody cares because I'm
funny and I do a lot of gory stuff
you're what every thirteen-year-old boy
thinks he can be except with an army of
writers and the ability to dub him
better jokes in case they think of them
later yes you couldn't do them I wasn't
wearing the mask so Deadpool has Francis
in his clutches Colossus is like you
can't do that I'm going to talk about
what it means to be a real hero and I'm
gonna go on and on even though the
entire audience has already guessed the
joke and they're just waiting for you to
pull the trick thank you
I'm gonna see if they keep me rushing in
x-men apocalypse so Deadpool meets up
with his girlfriend and he's like I know
I'm really ugly and you're really
beautiful but I'm kind of hoping we can
do that early 2006 camping where the
really hot chick gets together with the
unattractive guy I think if we want to
give her main demographic any hope we
better end on an in-joke and on an
in-joke
i Ferris Bueller and cables gonna be in
the next movie hurry so Deadpool it's a
lot of fun I especially like the parts
where he looked right into the camera
and talked to the people but isn't it
kind of distracting when he does that I
mean doesn't it just draw more attention
to the fact that he's a fictional
character doesn't that make it so
friggin obvious that the illusion it's
just totally shattered
this is jittery bum sing I have a
nostalgic track to shoot
no no closing light I have work to do